this is a rare Persian rug that's
appraised at an estimated 12 500 and
it's about to get its first cleaning in
more than two decades it's a delicate
job and not just because this antique is
so valuable it's also a family heirloom
and the clients are trusting the team at
Rosati rugs to deep clean it carefully
the goal is to remove the accumulation
of dirt and stains without harming the
rugs coloring Ali Rosati inspects the
fibers carefully to determine how the
rug was originally dyed this key detail
will determine how he'll complete the
job without causing any damage so his
clients can continue to pass down this
treasure for Generations so my clients
aunt had this rug for about 20 years and
she was very hesitant to have it clean
because she was afraid that it would get
ruined I know this is a 1940s rug
because they used vegetable dyes in
comparison to a 1960s temporary's like
this one here there's a specific process
to cleaning vegetable dye rugs I know
that I can use a deep wash because the
dyes won't run this is the pool that we
have the rugs clean and we have a drain
right here it's built on an angle so
that when we put a rug on either side
the water will just go right through
directly into the drain
one of Ali's team members Begins the
cleaning process by applying Browning
treatment to the stains this works to
remove tannin type stains like urine
fruit juice beer or soil as well as
general discoloration due to age
this 1940s Sheikh mashayaki rug has
collected stains from various family
gatherings throughout the years but
that's not all that makes this
strawberries rug unique what makes it so
special is not only the technique of
weave and the fine weaving on the back
but also the design and the color
combinations that are used as well after
letting the Browning treatment sit
minutes he hoses down the rug and
applies shampoo
next he agitates the fibers with a
scrubber which loosens up the
accumulated dirt and brings it to the
surface so the scrubber or the buffer is
used to help scrub and expand the use of
the shampoo throughout the rug and it
does it in a fast and efficient way so
if you were to actually hand do this Not
only would you get tired physically but
it wouldn't be as effective
Ali estimates that the original Weaver
made only a few hundred of these rugs
decades ago the coloring also dates back
to a time when Master Weavers used
different techniques this rug is made
with vegetable dyed wool which means the
coloring came from natural materials
like plants fruits or tree bar this
method is more labor intensive which
adds to the rug's value
Chrome dyes come from chemicals that are
used and boiled to create certain colors
Chrome dyes were used to decrease the
cost of rug weaving so in terms of price
point they are less in comparison to
rugs that have vegetable dyes
Incorporated in them as you can see this
type of a red tone is so bright you only
see that in Chrome dies but with
vegetable dyes they're a little bit more
subtle in comparison
the transition from vegetable dyes to
Chrome dies in the mid 20th century
brought about a new era in rug making
Chrome dies offered a wider and more
affordable range of Hues which
revolutionized the industry but the
legacy of those early Persian rug makers
is still visible today in rugs like this
which is why it's so important to
preserve it
the team member rinses the rug and
pushes a squeegee across each section to
remove excess water he repeats this step
several times throughout the cleaning
process to remove as much water as
possible
he runs the scrubber across the rug
again to loosen any remaining dirt and
then uses the extractor to lift the
stains and remove moisture
the extractor actually has two purposes
you can one just use it as a vacuum you
just place it on the rug and you start
pulling it towards your direction and
starts extracting the water out so that
the rod gets to dry faster also it has
another feature where if you press on
the lever not only will it extract water
but it'll expel hot water at the same
time and those are great for taking away
stains because you could do that
multiple times on a certain area
all the rugs are heated to a high
temperature of I'd say about 90 degrees
on average and they're hung right here
the rock must be completely dry before
moving on to the next step if not the
excess moisture can lead to mold and
mildew two factors that can deteriorate
the fibers in the rug
we'll go inside of the drying room and
we'll examine it and touch the pile of
the rug the fringes and the other
aspects of the rug to see if it's still
moist or not if we feel it is we'll keep
it in there the room is dry to a very
high temperature and just having all the
fans and dehumidifiers usually having a
rug in there for about a day would
completely dry it out
the quality of weave on tebodies rugs is
based on something called Raj which
counts the number of linear knots every
seven centimeters which is roughly two
and a half inches the higher the ratch
the higher the quality which also makes
a rug more valuable so in today's market
I would estimate this value around
twelve thousand five hundred dollars you
have these lines that are showing on the
back side of the rug and when you look
at those lines you'll be able to
actually count how many knots are in
between each line and so this specific
rug is 50 ratch on a lower quality
tabreeze you'll have a 20 radish this is
actually a lower quality tippers you can
see how big the knots are in comparison
to this Rook here these knots are a lot
more tight this is around that 20 radge
that I had mentioned earlier and then
you have the 50 reg which is a more
higher quality 60 RADS would be very
exceptional and then you'll have like 80
or 90 ratch which are extremely rare to
find and those type of rugs take close
to 10 years to make but this type of a
caliber I'd say in terms of Rarity on a
scale of 1 to 10 it would be a seven so
when you look at the different color
combinations and designs that are used
in this rug it seems like there's a lot
of religious symbolism going on and that
makes sense because was a religious man
within his region and the predominant
use of green is of Islamic religious
significance because green was the
prophet Muhammad's favorite color I've
grown up with Persian rugs in my home
and there's a lot of deep cultural
significance to Persian rugs and the
history behind it so I feel very akin to
my culture being in this industry
the rug looks magnificent it's much
brighter than it was before and the
majority of the stains have been removed
there are a lot of other people in this
industry that really don't put their
heart into it they just clock in and
clock out but each rug is
a portion of a person's home and I take
that responsibility to heart that when
they bring their rug to me they're
bringing a part of their home
into my life
for me to take care of
foreign
[Music]